[Music]
hi everyone welcome my name is Yu Feng
Guo you can find me on Twitter at you
Fang Zhi and today we are going to talk
about the path from Auto ml to a custom
model my name is Sarah Robinson you can
find me on twitter at s robb tweets and
here's what we're gonna cover today
we're gonna talk about all the machine
learning tools available on google cloud
platform
then we'll start with building a model
using auto ml natural language then
we'll build a similar model using tensor
flow and cloudy a platform and finally
we'll wrap up and share some resources
with you so one of the great things
about all the machine learning products
on Google cloud is that you don't need
to be a machine learning expert to get
started
so with this pyramid you can kind of
choose your level of abstraction so the
products that we're gonna show you
towards the bottom are targeted at folks
that may have more machine learning
expertise the product as we move towards
the top are targeted more towards
application developers so at the lowest
level we have these open source popular
machine learning frameworks so if you're
building a model at this level you're
writing all of the code for the model by
hand each of the layers and you'll need
to figure out what infrastructure you
want to use to train and serve your
model next up on our abstraction pyramid
our deep learning VM images these are
prepackaged virtual machine images that
have machine machine learning libraries
installed on them already so you don't
have to install them by hand and
additionally if you want to add things
like GPUs to that instance you don't
need to worry about installing the
drivers to power those GPUs those will
also be taken care of for you
next up we have cube flow which is an
open source project created by Google
but lets you deploy a machine learning
pipelines on kubernetes containers and
cube flow has this concept of components
so you can break your pipeline up into
individual components for pre-processing
data training and serving then we have
cloudy aya platforms training and
prediction services which abstracts away
some of the manual work around scaling
up training and prediction and allows
you to kind of have a managed service to
take care of that for you moving up the
stack we have big query machine learning
which lets you take structure data
stored in bigquery and run it through a
machine learning model all you need to
do is choose the type of model you want
to use and with a single sequel query
you can have a model trained and ready
for prediction auto ml allows you to
have custom models customized to your
data set and you don't need to do any
code for make setting up that model and
you can train and serve those models
finally our machine learning API is let
you access pre train models with a
single REST API request so you don't
need any of your own training data if
you want to accomplish a common machine
learning task these ml api's are a great
way to get started and since we don't
have a ton of time today we're gonna
focus just on three of these tools so
we're gonna start by building a model
with Auto ml and then we'll build a
model using tensorflow
deploy it on AI platform so before we
dive into each of these components I
just want to make sure that we're all on
the same page around kind of what we're
calling machine learning and how and
give us a framework to think about how
these tools all fit together into this
workflow and so at a high level we can
say machine learning is using data to
answer questions and so when we break
that out into kind of a structure we can
think of the data as training inputs and
that goes through our machine learning
model and we can answer our questions or
get labels or predictions or classes
from the model and so you can swap out
these things for real examples so you
could have almost any type of input to a
machine learning model one example is a
picture so the input to our model here
is the pixels in this image of our cat
and our model outputs the label cat we
could also have text as input to our
model so we could take the headline of
this article about a Raspberry Pi and
build a model to categorize the article
so in this example it'll categorize it
as a technology article so we were
thinking about situations where we could
use a machine learning model to predict
some sort of a useful label on text and
so being developers we naturally this
led us to thinking about Stack Overflow
I've got some text and we need to tag
them with something right there's lots
of great tags on Stack Overflow for all
sorts of questions and in particular in
the machine learning space we have lots
of different machine learning libraries
and we thought you know how
pathetical world wouldn't it be neat if
while we're typing a question into Stack
Overflow it told us some recommended tax
maya tags that make sense based on the
question that we're asking so first to
do this we'll need lots of training data
luckily there's a data set available as
part of the bigquery public data sets
program it has lots and lots of Stack
Overflow questions to be exact it has 26
gigabytes of Stack Overflow questions
over 17 million rows so we're gonna use
this table to get some training data for
our model and with that data we're going
to use that as our training data and
push that through Auto ml and auto amel
will give us the ability to train up a
model without needing to worry about the
model architecture and we can really
just focus on getting the data into the
right form making sure it is exactly
what we want and none of the things we
don't and then at the end we'll have a
REST API that we can call and get
predictions from so let's dive in and
take a look at what that looks like so
in our example that question we saw
earlier we would go into Auto ml and
with for our first pass let's just try
to categorize questions as either a test
flow or not and so in this example of
course it would be tensor flow and to
get this data together Sara mentioned we
have the bigquery public data sets and
thanks to bigquery is a very robust
sequel engine we can do a couple of
pre-processing steps right out of the
gate and there's a couple of really
useful functions on Vickery we really
got a chance to dive into some of the
functionality there that kind of extends
beyond just the standard sequel body of
functionality and operate on these big
data sets so one of the things we first
noticed when we looked at the questions
is that in this public data set there's
HTML tags just everywhere there's pre
tax code tags paragraph tags bolding
italicizing wouldn't want any of that
right none of that is useful for
identifying whether someone is asking
about a test flow question or a
different machine learning library so
we're gonna strip all those out the tags
also happens to be separated with
vertical bars not great if I want to
make my data look anything like a CSV so
replacing those with commas and in this
example we're gonna pull out just kind
of related machine learning libraries
we're not going to try
to tackle the bigger problem of tagging
questions you know even web development
questions ask kinds of flow or not and
just sick within kind of this subdomain
so hold on a second
couldn't you just write an if statement
I feel like most tensor flow questions
have tensor flow in them at some point
so you could do something like if tensor
flow then the tag equals tensor flow
maybe you don't even need machine
learning for this this is true people do
love writing tensor flow when they're
asking about tensor flow questions and
this applies to a lot of questions on
Stack Overflow right like if you're
asking a question about pandas you're
probably saying in pandas how do I do X
and then maybe you paste in some code
and in that code you write import pandas
as PDF there's pandas again and so Stack
Overflow is kind of an interesting space
where the tags oftentimes line up
directly with the questions being asked
however that's not always the case a lot
of times for questions we will just
people just dive right in
no just come out and Lotus say stuff and
they might not even bring up what
library they're using they just want to
know this specific detail and they
perhaps rely on the tag to indicate what
library they're talking about or what
context they're using and so we want to
train a model that can be robust to
these model mains because if we just
have a model that just looks for tensor
flow somewhere in the question is that's
hot there's tensor flow it's not a
really good model right that's not
really machine learning that's an if
statement and so what we can do is take
our data set and we're going to replace
all instances of the word tensor flow
and matplotlib and pandas scikit-learn
and PD and PLT and TF and carrots we're
gonna replace that all with the same
work and what better were to replace our
machine learning libraries with an
avocado it will prevent our model from
cheating and we'll have lots of avocados
everywhere and everything is better with
more avocados you know you're toast your
datasets just everywhere so lots of
avocados and so here's an example of
some of these the pieces of data we've
already stripped out those HTML tags and
some of those new lines so everything is
kind of compressed down there right and
because a lot of times Stack Overflow
questions will be a little bit long you
got a scroll or scroll and scroll we
want to make it so we can see more of
them
in a window you can see some of these
questions that are tagged with a couple
of different libraries and you know you
can look at learn about the avocado
dataset and import avocado from avocado
and avocado layers and look at avocados
predictive models its avocados
everywhere so let's see what happens now
as we pull this data into our own now
and we'll switch over to the demo and
look at kind of what it looks like
really on auto amel
great so we have here this is the view
of when I pulled the data into auto ml
and we can see kind of some examples of
the various text that we have lots of
avocados everywhere and we have our two
tags other and avocado there's just as
much avocado and the other tag as there
is in the tensorflow tag so the model
won't be able to distinguish between
questions that have lots of tensorflow
in them and the questions that don't and
so once we've trained up a model it'll
take us to the evaluation folder
training takes longer than the time we
have here unsurprisingly given our the
size of our data set and kind of the
complexity we're hoping to achieve here
so Auto ml natural language you know
uses a number of different natural
language processing approaches to try to
find the best model that we can get and
so here you know I would say we did
pretty well here right like I all I had
to do is sit train and then we just you
know went off we worked on our slides we
did other things and at some point I got
an email that said Oh your model is done
training and so it's like oh great now I
can just come back and and see how it
did I mean it really it really saved
there's a lot of effort there's no
debugging of code there's no I mean
there's debugging of the sequel code
before but once we start training it got
a lot easier and so we can even check
out the confusion matrix right because
we only have those two classes we can
kind of show that and what's neat about
this confusion matrix is instead of just
having a kind of bland confusion matrix
for us to look at we can actually click
into these and we're getting all this
for free I don't have to write any code
to go and identify things like false
negatives and questions that should have
been predicted other in this case but
we're labeled as tensorflow or questions
that
we're predicted as other but it should
have or the other way around it's sure
to predicted ten service so we can see
some of these questions that are not
accurate right and then kind of zero in
on why that might be we can adjust our
data we can address our approach we can
adjust how we go about this process and
so it's it's really kind of a useful
thing there so let's go up and we can
click predict here and what we'll do is
grab an actual stack overflow question
all right so let's say here's one
it's about simplifying URLs for dotnet
and it's clearly not tensorflow
if I do say so myself and what we can do
is we can paste that text into the
predict box so sometimes when you finish
training I was like oh here's a rest
endpoint good luck with that go and
figure out offense ocation on your own
right off from code run it then you can
call it but it's really nice that we
have this text box here that we can
actually just click predict and see what
we get back and so you can test all
sorts of you know text into the body
here so that's our has Tenzer flow model
so let's switch back to the slides and
look at how we can improve on this right
because knowing whether or not a model
is tensorflow or not is not that
earth-shattering if I do say so myself
you can you can do better than that
right we can Tangier across all those
tags that we saw charismatic andas I
could learn we should be able to get a
question and not just say oh this is not
tensorflow but that this is pandas and
we can use that same data set we did
before but kind of process it a little
bit differently instead of saying
tensorflow or other will actually write
out the specific library that is is
using and our data set across these five
kind of tags you know there's a good
number to work with for each one which
is nice and so let's see what that looks
like we'll switch back over to the demo
station and you know here we'll jump
straight to the evaluate screen and we
can see our five tags
overall the precision and accuracy were
good we can click into one of these
let's say pandas
and we can look at the specifics around
each of these tags and again see the
true positives examples of false
negatives and examples of false
positives across each of these tags so
you know you can click into these and
actually see specific examples the full
example not just the excerpt and you
know the predictions in detail as well
as coming back and you can notice
there's a delete button so in some cases
you might have data that you're
generating yourself and you might find
like oh that that's just an erroneous
piece of data I just need to get rid of
it it's actually not supposed to be in
my data set right we're pulling data
from Stack Overflow but your data might
come from user data that people might
have typed in garbage it might be
malformed in some way so again we'll go
and find an another stackoverflow
question here's a question about carrots
and we can copy that question into the
predict tag and we can test out how how
it does right so we're hoping that
Kerris will be one of the top tags that
come back so we see that it comes back
with a great amount of probability it
also thinks that pandas it might be
related and that very marginally
tensorflow also might be related another
example is with kind of a question that
touches across a couple of different
things we got pandas we got data frames
and we got Carris and so we can paste
that in and run predict on it and we get
you know very strong signals around
carrots and there's a little bit of
tensorflow
on the side too like because Karis is
after all now largely folded into
tensorflow and so one of the things that
might be worth pointing out here is that
you'll notice the numbers don't add up
to one because we're predicting across
five different classes the breakdown
isn't a strict probability distribution
because it can have multiple tags that
come back not just the one true tag so
to speak so let's switch back to the
slides and we'll click through the
screenshots in the event of live demo
failure and now we'll move on from kind
of the auto ml use cases to a more
custom machine learning workflow and why
might we want to do that why would we
move on from something that works really
well right we're seeing really
good results it seems that we can just
click train and then we can just get a
sandwich I don't do anything else but
perhaps we want to solve a more custom
problem or maybe we have different
inputs not just text but text plus
images all in the same model or maybe we
just want to learn more about custom
natural language modeling and add that
to our machine learning tool belt so
we'll kind of try to go through this
process in a way that isn't just you
know draw a circle and then boom there's
an owl we'll try to get the steps in
between as well so that we can kind of
show that roadmap more clearly so I'll
toss it over to Sara and who will kind
of go through this process
Thanks you think I'm so before we dive
into some code let's talk about what we
mean by a custom model so when we say
custom model here we're gonna be writing
code in this example we'll be using
tensorflow and care us we'll write code
to pre-process our data define our model
architecture define each of the layers
of our model
we'll run training and evaluation we
will deploy our model and then we will
get predictions from our trained model
so machine learning models can a lot of
times seem like a black box and a lot of
magic it's actually not magic under the
hood it's just a bunch of matrix
multiplication so if any of you remember
y equals MX plus B from your algebra
classes this may look familiar
so when you train a machine learning
model you have inputs which are your
features and then you have your
prediction the thing you're trying to
label and then you also have these
weight and bias matrices and the idea is
that as you continue training you find
the optimal values for these weight and
bias matrices to get accurate
predictions so obviously when you start
training these matrices will be
randomized your predictions won't be
very good as you continue training they
will get better hey Sarah this seems
really reasonable with kind of numeric
data here we even took the time to make
sure these matrix multiplies were
correct how does this then apply to
other data formats like we have here
with our text data that's a good
question may not be super obvious of how
to convert any type of data to a matrix
but you can actually represent pretty
much any type of data in matrix format
so in this image example we have this
color image of a cat and really all an
image is is just a bunch of pixels so
this particular image every pixel has a
red green
an RGB value so this image becomes three
matrices of RGB values let's say you
have categorical data so let's say
there's a column in our data set and it
has three possible values the string
sitting stretching or running to
describe different actions so the way
you represent categories for a machine
learning model is you do what's called
one hot encoding so you create arrays
where the number of elements equals the
number of possible categories for that
particular feature and then all of the
indices are 0 except for 1 which
corresponds with that particular feature
now you may be thinking wouldn't be way
easier if we just encoded these
numerically as 1 2 3 that would be
easier but then our model would
interpret these as continuous numerical
values so we would interpret stretching
is greater than sitting running is
greater than stretching which isn't
necessarily true so we'd want our model
to treat all these different categories
equally and then finally for freeform
text which is the type of data that
we're dealing with there's lots of
different ways you can encode freeform
text as matrices we're gonna be talking
about one specifically called
bag-of-words this is my favorite one to
get started with if you're new to
natural language processing so what this
method does is it treats you can think
of it as a bag of Scrabble tiles where
instead of a letter on each tile you
have a word on each tile so all of the
inputs to your model all of our Stack
Overflow questions are individual bags
of words so it won't be able to detect
the order of words in a sentence but it
will be able to detect the presence or
absence of certain words and you think
is going to tell us a little bit about
how bag of words works so I guess in our
case though instead of a bag of words we
might have some avocados mixed into that
bag a bag of avocados so in this kind of
simplified example just to talk us
through the concepts let's pretend that
we do not know English
our entire vocabulary we're learning
English and the only words we know in
the entire world are those ten listed
there under vocabulary data frame layers
series graph it's a very technical
approach to learning a language as
opposed to learn these words first but
be that as may then we have these labels
and we'll simplify down condense it for
this purpose to just three labels Kerris
pandas in that public flip so we're
gonna try to use bag of words
to categorize sentences as one of those
labels but we only know those 10 words
right so if we go to the next slide we
can see a example sentence how to plot
data frame bar graph not the best
English perhaps but when we look at it
we only recognize three words plot data
frame and bar graph the rest of it is
all gibberish right so pretend you don't
know what the words how to and bar mean
at all that's just nonsense words and so
when you look at that what you can do is
you can then encode from your very
limited vocabulary of ten words that
sentence we can encode that sentence
based on the position within our
vocabulary so our vocabulary is gonna be
ordered and so we see ah in this
sentence there's the word data frame it
happens to be the fourth word but we're
gonna say that it's going to turn on the
first bit in our array because data
frame is the first word in our
vocabulary it's the first word we
learned ever let's say and the fourth
word in our vocabulary is graph it's the
last word in the sentence but we're
gonna turn on the fourth bit in that
array to a one and so this is kind of
why it's called it backwards because we
don't care about the order of the words
in the inputs it's like we took the
sentence broke it up into words and just
toss them into a bag pulling out one
word at a time and only recognizing the
ones we knew so we pull out a word and
says data friend aha we'll turn on the
first bit pull out a word it says bar I
don't know what that is throw it out
then we pull out another word says plot
aha I know what that word is that's the
sixth word turn on that bit and so when
you finish grabbing all the words out of
the bag you have an array that has
encoded the sentence based on your
understanding your representation of the
world and you do that for every sentence
in your data set and so now each example
has been encoded into this array that
has ones for all the words that showed
up in each of those respective sentences
and so this is kind of a graphical
representation of that right each word
kind of goes to the different spots in
our vocabulary and yields the ones and
zeroes and you can do the same thing for
the prediction it's a little more
straightforward there's only three words
and so whichever ones are the correct
labels for a given sentence will turn on
with once and leave the other values as
zeros
so this brings us back to our matrices
yes so now we know how to encode our
text as bag-of-words
so this is what the inputs will look
like to our model for this simple
example we just have a vocabulary of 10
as you'll see in a moment we'll use a
larger vocabulary for our stackoverflow
dataset a little bit a little bit bigger
and then our prediction is just an array
with the size of the number of labels
that we're using so how are we going to
build our custom model we're gonna be
using a variety of different tools to
pre-process our data we'll use bigquery
to get the data as you thing already
showed us we're gonna use the exact same
data set to train our custom model as he
used for the auto ml version will use
pandas which is a really handy Python
library for examining our data set doing
some feature transformations
we'll use a utility function from
scikit-learn
to encode our labels as multi how to
raise and then finally we'll use Kaos to
convert our text to bag of word matrices
we're going to use tensorflow to build
our models specifically the TF Kaos API
we will run training and evaluation in
collab collab is a cloud hosted
browser-based Python notebook and since
our model trains pretty fast we can run
it writing collab then we will deploy it
on cloud AI platform and generate some
predictions so what will the text what
will the code look like to encode our
text as bag-of-words luckily we don't
have to do the process of getting the
top words from our vocabulary and
converting them to matrices by hand
caris has a utility function to help us
with this it's called a tokenizer
so we instantiate our tokenizer by
telling it how many words we want it to
collect so it'll take the top 400 words
from our vocabulary in this example now
this is a hyper parameter you should try
with different values depending on the
size of your data set and the total
number of unique words in your text
corpus so then we train the tokenizer
on our text data by calling fit on texts
passing in our train question strings
and then we convert our text questions
to bag of words matrices using the text
to matrix function and then we will
build our model architecture so we're
gonna do this using the chaos sequential
model API
now this is my favorite API for building
models essentially it lets you define
your models as a stack of layers so
it'll be really easy in code to
visualize what our model looks like this
is gonna be a deep neural network which
means that it will have some hidden
layers in between our input and our
output layer so our first layer is going
to take an input of our vocab size which
is 400 so we're gonna take our 400
element bag-of-words array and then it's
going to convert that into a layer of 50
neurons and the way it's going to do
that computation is through an
activation function which is called Ray
Lu the great part about carrots is we
don't have to worry how that's
implemented under the hood we just need
to know the right activation function to
use we're gonna have one more hidden
layer so our model is going to take that
50 neuron layer and transform it into a
25 neuron layer again the size of your
layers is another hyper parameter that
you can use to experiment with different
values so the outputs of these hidden
layers aren't going to really be
meaningful to us our model is just using
them to represent complex relationships
in our data but what we do care about is
our output layer so our output layer is
going to be five neurons because there's
five possible tags in our data set and
we're going to use the sigmoid
activation function so let's talk a
little bit more about why we're using
Sigma here a lot of times we see
different activation functions in neural
networks and oftentimes in particular
softmax is a common other alternative
activation activation function that's
chosen that's a good question
so remember for this model it's a multi
label multi class model so that means
that our model could predict multiple
tags for a given question
so what sigmoid will do is it'll take
each of those five elements in our
output array which correspond with the
labels and it will return a value from 0
to 1 indicating the probability that
that question corresponds with that
label and the values will not add up to
1
since there could be more than one label
per question you said you've seen
softmax a lot which is a good point if
you instead had a model where you could
only have exactly one possible label per
input you would use softmax as your
activation function and what that would
do is it would still return that 5
element array but all of the inputs
would add up to one so here's an example
of our
of our machine learning models output
using sigmoid and we can see that in
this example there's a high probability
that this particular question
corresponds with the first and last
label in our dataset finally we'll
compile our model so that we can run
training and evaluation we pass it the
loss function we want to use this is how
our model calculates the error between
what it predicted and what it should
have predicted and this is the thing
that our model is trying to minimize the
optimizer we choose tells our model how
it will optimize those weight and bias
matrices after each iteration so running
training and evaluation in Karos is
pretty straightforward
we call model dot fit we pass it our
trained questions encoded as
bag-of-words our train labels
we're gonna run training for three
epochs this means that our model will
iterate over our entire dataset three
times the batch size is 64 which means
that our model will examine 64 elements
from our data set at once before it
updates the weights and then to evaluate
our model on our test data on data that
it's never seen before we just call
model dot evaluate we pass it our test
questions our test tags and the batch
size finally we're going to deploy our
model on AI platform with this new alpha
feature called custom code custom code
lets you run custom server-side Python
code as part of your prediction request
so this lets you configure how you pass
your inputs to your model how you format
them and also the format of the
prediction output so we're gonna make
use of this feature so that our client
can be super simple all I want our
clients to do is just pass the text to
our model and then on the server will
use that tokenizer we created to convert
it to a bag of words before we generate
the prediction if you want to try custom
code stay tuned for an announcement soon
if you want to try it really soon you
should fill out this form to request
alpha access and I will have a link to
this on the last slide so don't worry if
you don't get it now finally we will be
making predictions and we'll do this
using g-cloud the google cloud CLI we
can just call it predict on our model
pass it some examples in a text file and
we'll get our predictions so let's see
it in action if we could go to the demo
so here I have my collab notebook and
I've already run the first couple cells
so I'll just briefly explain what
happened there so here we are importing
all of our libraries that we're gonna
use for this we're then authenticating
there's collab instant so that it knows
about our cloud account we're
downloading that same data set that
you've been used for the auto ml models
and then we are converting our data set
to a panda's data frame so this is a
really nice way to visualize what our
data set looks like so our data set in
this form is a comma delimited string of
all of our labels we want to convert
this to a multi hot array so we need to
split that string up so what I've done
here in this next step is we've
converted each tag row to an array of
all the tags and then we're gonna use
multi label binarize err which is part
of the psychic Learn library so we've
then converted this array of string
labels to this one hot encoded array and
this is our lookup array of all the
possible labels in our data set then we
will choose our train size in this
example we will use 80% of our data for
testing Orford sorry for training and
then we'll reserve the other 20% for
testing so we've got a lot of questions
here and then we will split up our
encoded labels into the train and test
sets and then finally this is where
things get interesting I've written this
class to tokenize all of my text inputs
so we create that Kerris tokenizer
we train it on our training questions
and then we return that tokenizer
the text to matrix call so we return
that bag of words matrix and this cell
is is actually where I call that class
to create the bag of words matrices so
just to show you what this ends up
looking like before we feed it into our
model we have this is just the the first
example in the training set we have a
400 element array because we had a 400
word vocabulary size with a bunch of
ones and zeros indicating the words from
our vocabulary that are in this
particular question so now comes the fun
part of building and training our model
so what I just ran in this cell is we're
gonna use this Python tool called pickle
save the state of our tokenizer because
we'll need to use our tokenizer when we
make predictions here we're creating our
model and this looks exactly the same as
the code that I showed you on the slide
and then in this step is where we
actually train and evaluate our model so
you'll notice here that I use validation
split what this does is it takes a
subset of my training data and it uses
that to validate the model to make sure
that it's actually learning and it's not
overfitting to my training data so what
I want to see here is that the training
loss is decreasing but that the
validation loss is also decreasing if
the training loss was decreasing and
validation loss is increasing it might
be a sign that my model is overfitting
so now it is time to test that our model
locally having to point it to the cloud
yet so I have this class for generating
for pre-processing the text of taking
the text string converting it to bag of
words and then loading the model and
generating a prediction on it so here we
have to test strings which are from real
Stack Overflow questions and we will
call our custom model prediction class
and generate a prediction so we can see
that our model predicted Karos for the
first one with 91% probability and then
pandas for the second one it looks like
with 89% so our model is working it's
still just local to this collab instance
so the next step is to deploy it to
cloud AI platform so what we're gonna do
here is we will package up those scripts
that I just created I saved them to my
local collab instance and then we're
going to copy our saved model and our
tokenizer to a cloud storage bucket so
I'll run this command and then the next
command will package up all of my code
and set my current project to the one
where I'm hosting this demo
and now we're going to run the deploy
command I'm gonna change the name of the
model to next 2019 and we'll run that
deploy command and if we go over here to
our model let me zoom in and refresh we
should see that new version deploying so
while that deploys let's go back to the
slides and I'm going to talk about one
more thing so it's really important to
remember that behind these machines are
humans may sound really obvious but as
people that are involved in any part of
the model building or deploying process
we are responsible for the predictions
that are generated by our machine
learning models so this means it's
really important to take steps to make
sure that your training data is
representative of the people that are
going to be using your product so one
example is let's say we train a model to
identify 10 different types of cat
breeds and we train it on thousands of
images accuracy is really good 99% we
deploy it and someone comes along and
uploads a dog picture now our models
entire world view is just those 10 cat
breeds so it's going to probably try to
classify the dog photo into one of those
cat breeds maybe even with high
confidence so it's really important to
make sure that your training data is
representative of the people using your
product and also that your model is
using the right features to make those
predictions the good news is there's
lots of great open frameworks to help
with this I'm gonna use one in
particular called shop it's an open
source framework you can find it on
github and what shop does is it lets us
interpret the output of any machine
learning model and it can tell us which
features are most impactful in making
our models predictions the way that we
use shop first we import it and then we
create what's called an explainer object
there's a bunch of different types of
explainers as provided by shop we're
gonna use the deep explainer since we
have a deep model and we pass our deep
explainer our model and then a subset of
our training data and then we can call
chat values on our explainer object to
get the attribution values and what
these attribution values are is going to
be an array of the
length of the number of features we have
with attribution values on how each each
feature impacted our predictions so high
positive values would indicate that that
particular feature pushed our models
prediction up and low negative values
indicate that it pushed our prediction
down so Sarah this really sounds
straightforward for like your standard
structured data set you got a CSV file
you got columns with all sorts of
different attributes but we've got text
data here it's just free form all over
the place avocados everywhere how how
can we capture feature importance in a
text book that's a good question so
since we're using a bag of words model
and it's we've got a 400 word vocabulary
essentially what shap will do is it'll
treat each of those 400 words as
different features so we can look at the
attribution value for each word to
determine which words signaled our
models predictions so it's like having a
really wide table 400 call exactly or
injured column table great so what I've
done is create a visualization to
highlight the top five signalling words
in blue and the lowest signalling words
in red so what we have here is a
question that is about matplotlib and
our model is picking up on these
specific words to make the prediction so
it's it's picking up on the words color
PLT fig axe and then words like data or
the number four are contributing least
to our models predictions so this is
good because it shows us that our model
is working relatively well if instead it
was picking up on words like for in or
the to make predictions we may want to
go back and revisit our training data
here's an example for tensorflow
and I actually use shop to help improve
this demo so the first time that we ran
it I sent you Fang a screenshot I was
like hey look it's using the word
tensorflow to predict that this is
tensorflow maybe we should take that out
of the question
perhaps so that's how we decided to use
the avocado replacement to make sure
that our model is working really well so
for the tensorflow example it's picking
up on words like variable session graph
this is a panda's example it picks up on
column data frame and the negative
signal words are four and each and so
let's see
this shop in action so if we could go
back to the demo it looks like our next
2019 model finished deploying so right
yes so we can go generate some
predictions so we're going to write
these predictions to a text file and I'm
going to change the version that I'm
getting predictions from and I'm using
g-cloud here to get predictions on my
train model and we can see that it works
we get two arrays of five elements and
we will visualize those predictions a
little bit nicer here so we can see that
for the first one it predicted chaos the
second one predicted pandas so now comes
interpreting our model with shop so to
do that we will first pip install shop
and this library called colored which I
use to color the output text in blue and
red so since those are not included in
collab we will install them and once
they're done installing we will create
our shop explainer just like the code
that I showed on the slide and our
Chara's tokenizer is actually a
dictionary corresponding with word
frequencies we are going to turn this
into a list so that we can use it to
look up the corresponding words with
each feature attribution number so one
handy function that shop has is this
summary plot function and what this
tells us is the words that have the
highest magnitude in our models
prediction so it's not necessarily the
highest positive value it could be high
negative values as well so we can see
for example the effects that each word
has on a particular prediction so data
frame is impacting pandas predictions
most which makes sense it's probably a
negative signal word for tensorflow and
matplotlib and then for plot we can see
that's signalling matplotlib most and
perhaps a negative signal word for
pandas so you can see a couple examples
of the top signal words there and I've
written this function to color our text
the top five highest and lowest
signalling words so we'll just print a
couple of examples here so this is a
panda's example we can see it uses the
words column not a number
words like generic words like use or
does
signal the predictions too much for
tensorflow we get sash ops tensor and
these words that are related some of
them to other other labels in our
dataset are pushing the prediction down
so those are negative signal words and
then I'll just scroll through some other
examples here we have another Kerris
example words like LS TM layer dense
which are pretty common words you may
recognize if you've ever built a model
in chaos and then we have a couple more
examples here and one last last one on
matplotlib so that's a simple example of
how you can use shap and if we could go
back to the slides so during this
session today we've kind of gone from
getting our data set together loading it
up with avocados and then pumping it
through auto ml we did one with tensor
flow or not and we did a model which
categorized tensor flow map pileup and
there's across a couple of different
libraries and so that's perhaps is like
a more robust version of that approach
and then we went and kind of built up a
similar model from scratch using a bag
of words or bag of avocados approach and
then we ran that in colab deploy that
model to cloud platform and use the
prediction service to actually make
calls and get predictions back and then
we fed that into shap
to interpret our model to figure out
what words in each example contributed
most and contributed least to
identifying the labels that it created
so just wrap up these are resources to
all of the different products and
open-source projects that we covered i'm
one thing to note we are working on
model interpretability support for AI
platform so if you have a use case for
that would really love to hear what you
think and to stay in the loop on updates
on that feature please fill out this
form at the bitly link it's at least
model - interpret - interest and if you
want to try out the custom code feature
that I demoed when I deployed my model
you can fill out this form to request
access to the alpha bitly /cm le -
custom
could sign up and finally we would
really love your feedback on this
session so please remember to go into
the app and add your feedback on the
feedback form thanks everyone for coming
great
[Applause]
[Music]